regarding drones,
everything is transparent enough and everything is
clear enough, but I will still speak,
first of all, Ukraine
has absolutely nothing to do with this, because there is no
military value in such actions, and
secondly, it is definitely important for us to destroy
all Russian military facilities on
occupied territories in order to
speed up the de-occupation of these territories,
this is a strategic plan, strategic
goals and strategic understanding, everything else.
infrastructure in Ukraine, and
therefore it is very important to record
two strange events that happened
today, firstly, the detention of alleged
Ukrainian saboteurs in Crimea who were supposed to
commit tourist acts in Crimea, and
secondly, the drones over the main talk about
Russia's preparation of a certain informational
background, a certain background for justifying  of its
large-scale tourism actions, so let's
see what Russia will do. Ukraine once
again emphasizes that there is definitely no
drone attack on the Kremlin as a target.
Everything is very simple in Russia. There are simply no victories in Russia.
It can no longer motivate its
society and it may no longer be able to
send just like that.  due to the death of his
soldiers, he can no longer motivate
his state, he has no victory on
the field, the second army of the world lost in battle,
they are not able to occupy Ukraine,
they were repulsed by us, now he
needs to somehow motivate these people
so that they go forward, except for those
Wagnerites who are forming  from the prisoners who,
if they do not go forward and turn
back, they shoot them themselves